When the Indian Ocean tsunami struck in late 2004,...
...Day wanted to put his experience to use and make a difference in the lives of survivors.
He flew to Sri Lanka to talk with relief organizations about how he could help.
They suggested money.
Day had a better idea.
You can do a large scale bicycle program,...
...the impact would be huge!
So then we selected a partner,...
...and together we delivered 24,400 bikes into Sri Lanka...
...all locally sourced and manufactured.
That experience planted the seed for what became World Bicycle Relief.
Now, Day's charity is focused on Sub-Saharan Africa.
That's essentially what's doing all the shifting internally and used in a more conventional shifter type.
SRAM's expertise has helped World Bicycle Relief put a more durable and affordable bike...
...locally manufactured onto the rugged roads and trails of Zambia.
The nonprofit also trains local mechanics to repair the bikes.
Day says the program has put more than 50,000 bikes into circulation in Zambia.
The rewards for the riders are immediate.
With a bicycle, you can go get fresh water.
With a bicycle, you can go get medical care.
With a bicycle, you can go to your job or find a better job.
So, it doesn't provide you fresh water,...
...but it gives you the ability or the access to it.
And it's all about access.